Yeah.
And then he decided to bulk up how many picos all vomit.
No killing.
Who's testing,
nobody's testing.
If we got Picos in your,
you saw that your gifts,
the thing when you are a young guy and you're indulging in various ways to
enhance your physical recovery and then you get off of that stuff,
you're going to have an adaptation period and that adaptation period,
I mean this is an issue.
It's,
hold on.
Why is it an issue?
It's a non issue.
Well,
the issue is your performance is going to suffer if you're saying if you're
going off it,
if you're on,
if you're on it and you get off of it.
[inaudible] he's a young guy.
If he's on it,
we're assuming he's on,
we don't know Gordon.
Yeah.
Oh I dunno.
What would you say?
You just have phenomenal genetics.
Yeah.
Okay.
All jokes aside,
if you do find someone though,
not him,
let's say someone else,
let's say he just was taking genetics,
someone else that does it.
If they do do it and they're doing it in an untested forum,
like like submission,
grappling.
Correct.
Which most of you can get away with whatever you want.
Eddie Meyers generalists tests like speaking completely.
Honestly,
we,
we know for a fact that some competitors are indulgent.
I don't know that.
Okay,
well I'll,
I'll say from,
I would say yes.
Okay.
I'm sure some are.
Every sport there,
the radiologist she did too.
We know for sure some,
right.
You know what,
I don't know to accuse any individuals,
but we know for sure summer when when you do have that situation where someone
is on something and then they get off of something,
then you have this adaptation period where they're,
their body's not producing testosterone as much anymore.
They're going to have to get on something else in order to kick start it back
up.
But you can do that.
You can do that.
But here's the thing too,
you know with this John Jones thinking the Pico granting and he did test
positive now with Vata,
right,
and they still allow him to fight.
Well.
Now let's say you are a Jujitsu guy who comes to the UFC and you did do stuff
prior and those Pico,
Pico Graham's get flagged,
right?
What do you mean?
Depends entirely on what you're,
what you're doing.
It depends entirely on who you are Joe.
Well No,
the with you sign it does not.
It depends entirely on what you're doing now.
General terms in terms of whether or not you get punished twice for the same
crime.
So if they can prove exactly the same way they approve with John the field,
one of the things is happening is that the testing is getting far better so they
can test you for stuff now that a year ago was absolutely impossible for sure.
So the threshold right now that they were saying this is where it's confusing to
me,
the threshold that they tested John was supposed to be more stringent than Vada.
Yes.
And then the,
the night of the fight,
this is where it gets weird to me.
The night of the fight to commission tested them all the same period,
same pice commission,
Usada and Vada all test him.
St Piss.
You cited,
didn't report anything.
Commission a report,
anything,
right?
Andy Foster,
clear him to fight.
But then Vata did.
Does he find it have better testing?
Now it's all the same.
So how's that possible?
So you think shenanigans with sign a yes,
I think it's shanks.
Here's the other thing,
Joe.
Here's what no one talks about with you Sada in the rule book,
no matter if it's Picos,
whatever is,
if you get flagged,
it doesn't matter if it's from residue whatevers,
you cannot compete until that is out of your body.
That's the rule book black and white.
It doesn't say,
well if Spico grant just still good,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
But do you understand that he's not testing positive for the actual steroids?
Again,
that doesn't matter.
That tablet in the rubric,
it doesn't say that.
And the robots,
yeah.
It says if you test pop regardless,
what is you,
we can offer the metabolites.
We cannot grant you the license to compete.
Interesting.
Which is interesting to me.
Well now I'm not saying they should.
This is why they don't suspect this.
Why?
I honestly think why they're doing this because they don't know exactly how this
is happening.
I think they have their,
their theories,
which you know,
it works right now,
but ultimately they don't really know what's going on.
So if they were to suspend John and he's really not taking shit,
who the fuck out of them?
So I think that's what's going well.
There's that.
And then there's also this concept of double jeopardy that they've already
punished him for having this stuff in a system is no indication that he has
recently taken it.
That's not the only hat,
Joe,
I understand.
But they're making the rules up as they go along,
which is an issue because if this was Corey Anderson,
phenomenal fighter,
not the same drawing powers.
John,
what happens at gala?
Scary argument.
The evening,
if they're making it up as they go along,
the parameters are changing.
So the ability to test things is changing.
So if someone takes,
say you take creatine,
creatine is tainted and you have some forbidden substance in your system and
it's supposed to only stay in your system for six months if it's this certain
stuff.
But now the testing gets better.
And so now instead of punishing you for something that you accidentally took,
and then they test you and they say,
oh,
we can prove that you accidentally took it,
so we'll only going to give you a six on suspension.
But then after the six months is over,
they can still test it in you.
Why?
Because the testing has gotten better.
Well,
what do they do now?
Because in the past they would've said,
well,
you've,
it's time served.
This is the only argument for the,
the John John's thing that makes sense is that you don't want,
you want,
you don't want to punish a guy for something you've already punished him for.
If you've proven that it's,
this is what he took with it.
But the,
at the rule book is it's,
you can only compete when you pass the tab.
You bred this rule.
Yes.
Yeah,
yes.
Um,
yeah,
I had a discussion.
This is what me and channel went back forth on text.
But how does [inaudible] feel about this?
What does he think he shouldn't be allowed to compete?
Because his understanding,
because still no matter what you meant to take it or not,
right,
right.
The rule is if you do not pass the test,
we can't grant,
you're licensed a fight.
That is the rules as explained to most all of the fighters separate.
The real problem would be is what if it's proven at some point in time,
let's just say a big for riff.
What if rather,
what if it's proven one time that they can tell if you've ever taken anything
ever your whole life and they just disqualify anyone forever.
Even if it's an actual shit test.
But if that happened,
I know it's a problem.
You won't have a sport.
This thing is a weird thing.
This pulse,
here's where thing,
remember the metabolite.
They don't really understand.
Here's where it's weird.
It makes no sense.
With our youth thought of testing,
do you sought a testing?
Their parameters are based off Olympic testing,
right?
Based off suspending guys two to four years.
You know how fucked up that is to do a fighter like Josh Barnett that,
so how small is your window?
It's not,
we're not the Olympics.
Don't come every four years.
It's such a small window.
You suspend the guys for two to four years.
It's fucking silly question.
But if a guy does juice and he hurts someone and gets away with it and then you
catch them like you've been trying to catch them,
then you catch him.
How much should you suspend him for?
Save.
You got a guy who's hired some Victor Kanye type individual back when victor was
doing this with the,
uh,
the clear and he hired some guy and this guy gets him on some shit that no one
knows what it is.
And he's just running through people and he's looking like Yo Romero and
smashing people,
but pastor Bellevue and everybody's like,
I don't buy it.
Something's wrong.
And then one day you catch him,
you spent it for food.
So he shouldn't have a career ever again.
I don't know why she did it with years.
That's ridiculous.
Cause we're going based off the Olympic curriculum.
What's the real question is like how many people are cheating?
Right?
And what should the punishment be?
Should it be based on how many people are cheating or she'd be based on the
philosophy we're trying to get cheating out of the sport.
I don't know.
You ever going to get it out?
And as you saw the answer,
cause obviously some shady.
Do you wish,
do you wish that the Japanese were super crazy strict about steroids back before
pride?
No,
no,
no.
As a fan,
I think you saw this wouldn't have happened.
Right?
So Anderson was making a point the other day in a rational point for letting a
guy like him take something so that he could recover.
You know,
cause he's 40 years old,
he still enjoys fighting,
but his body doesn't produce testosterone in the right way anymore.
She's been trained,
he's beat.
Whether they tried that for a,
I remember they made that leap.
It was legal for awhile.
Fucked it all up.
And I don't mean over him and Pete or their green didn't have a testosterone use
exemption.
Vito or did it,
did it legitimately Dan Henderson deal legitimate.
So a few other guys that had a veto like,
all right,
well,
the
way works.
Yeah,
it's way worse.
And they don't test you,
buddy.
No,
it was like,
it was totally legal.
Just like insiders knew.
We knew where he got it too.
I remember there was a guy in our gym,
they're like,
he got TRT pass where like,
fuck man.